bonjour à tout bon jour à tous vous avez
suivi l'actualité comme moi audi s'ils
nous attaquent sur nos fondamentaux
cette situation n'est pas acceptable
d'autant plus qu'il s'agit de fausses
informations
premièrement il nous accuse d'avoir
gonflé nos tarifs de vente en gros vous
devez savoir tout ce que le prix de
vente en gros n'est pas fixée par l'asm
mais nous a été imposée par la
collectivité
c'est à dire le 6 mai le prix qui nous
est imposé ces 2 87 centimes ce prix est
contestée aujourd'hui parodie si il ne
se paient que 17 centimes cette
situation n'est pas acceptable et nous
accuse de nous enrichir
alors que nous n'avons pas touché un
centime depuis 2015
aujourd'hui on voit bien où je trouve
l'enrichissement par ailleurs je
voudrais signaler que sur les 87
centimes il n'ya que 63 centimes qui
devrait être versée la somme le reste
dans les états clés surtaxe comme vous
le savez sur une facture d'eau et à
d'autres postes
aujourd'hui il faut rappeler que cette
situation existe depuis 2000 15 depuis
que la cacem et auditions ont repris la
gestion
je dirais du lamentin du saint joseph
depuis cette date là nous nous sommes
évertués à fournir l'eau je dirais en
continu 24 heures sur 24 à audi si ça
représente dix mille bouteilles par
minute pour vous rendre compte et pour
cela nous n'avons pas touché un centime
nous battons pour être payé et nous
souhaitons je dirais être justement
rémunérés pour le travail que nous
faisons
on dit s'ils nous attaquent sur un
deuxième point sur la qualité de la
gestion de notre réseau c'est un
paradoxe
vous savez comme moi aujourd'hui que
notre rendement de réseau atteint 80%
sur l'asm c'est à dire que quand on
produit cinq sauts on n'en livre iv je
dirais à l'usagé pendant le même temps
au dc un roulement nos raisons qui est
inférieur à 60% à dire que plus de 40%
de l'eau est perdue avant d'arriver chez
l'abonné donc je dirais aujourd'hui
avant d'accuser asml ferait mieux de se
regarder
troisième point ce que nous sommes
attaqués c'est la présomption de
corruption
alors ça c'est un véritable comble une
diffamation
clairement quand on connaît leur
situation actuelle
bien entendu ne pas nous laisser faire
nous allons défendre et valoriser tout
le savoir faire de l'entreprise
valorisez votre expertise valorisez
votre professionnalisme et vous pouvez
compter sur moi je vais défendre les
couleurs et les valeurs de l'entreprise